c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soit il est bienvenus sur France 24 elle
a une ce soir salée kebabo l'ancien
opposant historique au Tchad nommé
Premier ministre après la prolongation
de la période de transition avant cette
nomination il était vice-président du
Conseil militaire de transition et en
charge du dialogue national un dialogue
largement boycoté nous l'écouterons dans
ce journal
journée de tension à Goma dans l'est de
la République démocratique du Congo des
violences sont éclatés ce matin après la
mort d'un jeune conducteur il avait été
tué par balle la veille par la police
nous serons à Kinshasa dans ce journal
et à la fin de cette édition on part au
Nigéria ou un professeur d'art a décidé
de divertir les personnes âgées dans les
maisons de retraite grâce à des casques
à réalité virtuelle reportage à suivre
son visage et son nom sont connus des
Tchadiens salés a été très longtemps un
farouche opposant du président Idriss
Déby mais après la disparition du
maréchal en 2021 l'opposant à rallier le
Conseil militaire de transition avec à
sa tête le fils de l'ancien président
aujourd'hui il a été nommé Premier
ministre après la prolongation de la
période de transition ça les kebabo a
aussi été en charge de l'organisation du
dialogue national de transition un
dialogue boycoté par une grande partie
de l'opposition et par les deux
principaux groupes rebelles pour lui
cette nomination est dans la logique de
son engagement dans la transition
écoutez-le il répondait aux questions de
notre correspondant à N'Djamena Mamadou
je pense tout simplement que c'est
l'aboutissement logique de ce qui a été
entrepris politiquement dans ce pays
depuis la disparition du président débit
nous sommes inscrits en partie moi-même
et beaucoup d'autres patriotes
dans l'engagement de faire en sorte que
les choses changent dans le pays elles
arrivent progressivement elles arrivent
c'est l'essentiel si je peux être obligé
dans mon pays que ce soit à l'intérieur
du pays que soit à l'extérieur du pays
pour que les choses avancent le plus
important il faut porter le message de
l'espoir pour tout le message du
changement à tout point de vue et
surtout les fronts c'est à ça qu'on va
se livrer
je vous le disais le nouveau Premier
ministre tchadien Salek et Zabo était un
opposant historique à 73 ans l'ancien
journaliste avait brigué à la
présidentielle 4 fois son portrait signé
Caroline lamboli
c'était un opposant historique au
président
Idriss Déby ce mercredi salut kebabo est
nommé Premier ministre
cet ancien journaliste de 75 ans dirige
l'Union nationale pour le développement
et le renouveau 4 fois candidats à la
présidentielle il était connu pour ses
attaques acerbe contre le président des
fins nous sommes en phase avec notre
peuple et je pense que il y a aucune
crainte d'élection en élection des
Bioman élu si vous prenez depuis 96
jusqu'en 2011 chaque fois il est mal élu
et je crois que c'est la dernière fois
qu'il sera mal élu la prochaine fois il
ne sera même pas en 2021 à la mort du
maréchal salé kenzaro change de discours
son parti rallye le gouvernement dirigé
par mahammat débit fils du président
défunt qui est proclamé chef de l'État
par l'armée
est alors nommé vice-président du comité
d'organisation du dialogue national
inclusif et souverain
le dialogue a été boycoté par une très
grande majorité de l'opposition
politique ainsi que les deux principaux
groupes rebelles début octobre la
transition est prolongée de deux ans et
lundi mahmat débit est à nouveau investi
à la tête du pays Kenza beau promet
aujourd'hui de l'accompagner dans une
grande œuvre et de mener à bien la
transition politique
la situation à sanitaire de plus en plus
préoccupante en nous gandal le ministère
de la Santé comptabilise une vingtaine
de victimes confirmées de l'épidémie
pour la première fois depuis le début de
cette épidémie le 20 septembre dernier
un patient atteint du virus est décédé à
Kampala la capitale le président yorhi
mosellini a pris la parole ce soir à la
télévision publique il appelle la
population à ne pas s'inquiéter les
détails avec notre correspondant dans la
région Clément dirôme
les 4 millions d'habitants de la
capitale ougandaise compaa s'inquiète du
premier décès des bola en ville confirmé
en ce début de semaine dans une
allocation télévisée ce soir le
président your werim ou Sévigny affirme
que ce patient aurait fui son village
caché son identité et visiter en
guérisseur traditionnelle dans une autre
région avant de finalement atterrir cet
hôpital de Kampala la capitale alors
selon le président les guérisseurs
devraient arrêter de recevoir des
patients en temps d'épidémie bevini a
aussi et surtout appelé le personnel
médical et les autorités à arrêter les
patients qui refusent l'isolation et
tente de fuir ce mercredi une réunion
d'urgence s'est tenue dans la capitale
ougandaise avec les ministères de la
santé des pays de la région tous se sont
engagés à communiquer rapidement entre
eux pour éviter la propagation de
l'épidémie et prendre des mesures de
contrôle strict aux frontières le
gouvernement ougandé a annoncé l'arrivée
la semaine prochaine de près de 500
premiers vaccins en développement
et au Cameroun c'est la variole du singe
qui sévit de nombreux cas ont été
signalés les régions du centre du
nord-ouest du sud-ouest du Sud et du
littoral sont touchés par l'épidémie
selon un rapport du ministère
camerounais de la santé il y aurait 39
cassés et deux décès les précisions de
notre correspondant à Yaoundé Marcel
amoko
l'alerte a été donné dans une
correspondance du responsable de la
santé publique de la région anglophone
du Sud-Ouest adressé à deux chefs de
disques de santé de cette région dans sa
correspondance le docteur Philbert Eco
et co confirme l'existence de cas de
variole du singe dans les districts de
Bangui et de Coumba après des tests
positifs effectués au Centre Pasteur de
Yaoundé une alerte qui venait ainsi
confirmer les conclusions d'un rapport
d'évaluation épidémiologique du
ministère gabonais de la santé en
rapport qui indique que 5 régions du
Cameroun sont touchées par l'épidémie de
variole du singe je rappelle que selon
l'OMS l'Organisation mondiale de la
santé la variole du singe est une
infection virale extrêmement contagieuse
qui se transmet des animaux vertébrés
notamment des singes et des rongeurs à
l'homme et se manifeste par une éruption
cutanée plus tueuse de la fièvre et des
troubles respiratoires pour le
gouvernement camerounais n'a toujours
pas annoncé les mesures qu'ils comptent
prendre pour lutter contre cette
épidémie qui a déjà fait deux morts
selon les chiffres officiels
direction l'est de la République
démocratique du Congo la tension est
encore montée d'un cran à Gomas ce matin
des manifestations spontanées ont éclaté
dans certains quartiers de la ville du
Nord qui vous ces manifestations sont
intervenus après la mort d'un jeune
conducteur abattu par un policier lors
d'un barrage routier les précisions
d'Aurélie bazarra qui [__]
des groupes de jeunes sont descendus
dans les rues de certains quartiers de
Gomas ils ont mis en place des
barricades la police a fait usage de
tirs de gaz lacrymogène pour disperser
les manifestants des témoins nous
rapportent avoir entendu des tirs de
sommation alors à l'origine de cette
colère la mort d'un jeune conducteur
abattu par un policier le drame s'est
déroulé hier vers 17h le jeune homme ne
se serait pas arrêté à un barrage et le
policier à tirer dans un tweet le
porte-parole du gouvernement Patrick
mouya parle d'une bavure policière pour
rappel les autorités militaires du Nord
qui vous ont lancé lundi des opérations
de bouclage cela consiste à exiger le
paiement des taxes sur les véhicules
Stewart window un membre de la lucha à
Goma nous expliquer qu'avec ces
opérations de bouclage la population
éprouve de la rancœur une population qui
a l'impression nous dit-il que les
autorités se concentre plus sur les une
recette fiscale que sur la sécurité de
la province aux états de siège depuis
plus d'un an un procès en flagrant ça
s'est ouvert aujourd'hui au tribunal
militaire de Goma il a été renvoyé au 20
octobre car la partie civile demande à
ce que la République comparaisse elle
aussi comme civilement responsable nous
précise une source judiciaire sur place
le policier pour violation des consignes
et meurtres
au Mali le président de transition le
colonel asimigo état s'est vu remettre
l'avant-projet d'une nouvelle
constitution ce mardi l'homme fort du
pays a rappelé que l'objectif de cette
loi fondamentale était de repartir sur
de nouvelles bases et de construire une
démocratie rénovée et un état mieux
organisé fin de citation
en Tunisie environ 500 personnes
manifestées à Zarzis dans le sud-est du
pays il réclamait aux autorités une
intensification des recherches pour
retrouver des migrants disparus en mer
il y a deux semaines une embarcation de
fortune partie de cette ville avec un
son bord 18 migrants à disparu huit
corps dont plusieurs de Tunisiens ont
été retrouvés lundi par démarre
on reste en Tunisie pour tout autre
chose le pays souhaite valoriser son
huile d'olive locale et créer un label
pour cela des entrepreneurs ont décidé
de former des oléologues des
dégustateurs spécialisés dans l'huile
d'olive il y a Blaise Lili sont allés à
leur rencontre
savoir sentir et déguster deux qualités
essentielles pour être un bon oléologue
celui qui déguste l'huile d'olive à la
manière d'un sommelier dans la médina de
sous ça l'est du pays cette
entrepreneuse montre les gestes
pratiques pour déguster l'huile
alors ce bruit c'est
l'intrusion de l'air en bouche pour
vraiment
diffuser l'huile et et révéler les
attributs en bouche c'est passionné
professionnel du secteur et agriculteurs
doivent savoir déceler les équilibres
chimiques et sensoriels du produit tu
sens la main de la pomme
le fruit thé le piquant et l'amertume
sont les attributs d'une huile de
qualité
Soraya veut créer une communauté de
dégustateurs qui saura mettre en valeur
les marques tunisiennes qu'elle expose
avec d'autres dans son bar à huile
c'est toute une jeune génération de de
d'agriculteurs de producteurs qui
investissent dans la qualité qui
investissent dans le terroir tunisien et
on veut vraiment qu'ils aient une
plateforme internationale en Tunisie il
existe déjà 22 panels de certification
mais le métier d'oléologue n'est pas
toujours connu dans la médina de Sfax
une association a décidé d'éduquer les
jeunes malvoyants dès le lycée à la
dégustation de l'huile d'olive
leur formatrice souhaite en faire des
experts de l'huile d'olive
l'idée est vraiment de montrer à ces
jeunes qui sont différents des autres
qu'il y a de nouveaux métiers très
accessibles pour eux
l'objectif attend de les standards
certificat international qui permettra à
ces jeunes d'avoir un diplôme reconnu
au nigérien professeur d'art a décidé de
divertir les personnes âgées dans les
maisons de retraite son outil les
casques de réalité virtuelle avec ces
casques VR les pensionnaires peuvent
s'évader sur des scènes de danse et de
musique mais faire aussi du tourisme en
visitant New York par exemple reportage
de notre correspondant au Nigeria Moïse
Gomis
c'est de pensionnaire de cette maison de
retraite de l'egos sune leçon de
méditation relaxation le casque qu'elle
porte lui permet de voir puis de répéter
les mouvements à accomplir depuis plus
d'un an ces résidents découvrent la
réalité virtuelle ils sont guidés par
couler à dévoiler un artiste multimédia
cet atelier stimule leur mémoire pour la
plupart ses anciens n'ont presque plus
de contact avec leur famille respective
les personnes âgées à se reconnecter
seraient intégrer et à vivre une
expérience magnifique cela les aide à
vieillir avec grâce avec cette
expérience elles peuvent se dire je suis
aimé accepter j'ai ma place dans la
société
la résidence Regina Mondy est dirigée
par cette religieuse catholique sœur
Antonia lutte contre l'isolement mais
aussi le mauvais traitement subi par de
nombreuses personnes âgées de sujets
tabou au Nigeria comme dans beaucoup de
pays africains la culture nigériane met
l'accent sur la prise en charge du 3e
âge par les familles pourtant à l’égoce
le mode de vie rend difficile
l'existence de certains vieux parents
chez leurs enfants
souvent on entend des cas de parents
logés et enfermés toute la journée par
leurs enfants parce qu'ils sont
accaparés à l'extérieur par leur quête
quotidienne d'un travail par exemple
test chaque exercice de réalité
virtuelle chez lui avant de les proposer
lors de ses ateliers il s'appuie sur le
numérique pour faire du développement
social cette excellence s'inspire de son
expérience familiale l'état de santé de
la seconde femme de son père victime
d'attaque cérébrale le pouce à l'époque
a trouvé des moyens d'interagir avec
elle après le décès de celle-ci il se
spécialise alors sur des thérapies
alternatives la transforme les gens en
leur faisant passer un bon moment ils
sont focalisés sur des choses positives
qui sont générées par la musique le
dessin des couleurs c'est un moyen
d'expression puissant qui peut même les
aider à changer leur perspective sur la
vie
intervient dans trois autres maisons
comme ces présidents et en stimulant la
mémoire de ses pensionnaires il adoucit
et rend plus digne leur femme vie
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'Afrique merci aux équipes en régime
merci à notre chef d'édition Celia
carracena et merci à nos correspondances
en qui se journal ne pourrait pas se
faire merci à vous de nous être fidèles
[Musique]